this morning a state of emergency is
still in effect for parts of South
Florida after a once in a thousand year
flood event soaked the Fort Lauderdale
area shutting down the airport and
schools and trapping people in their
cars the storm dropped more than two
feet of rain and Mobile jorcases in Fort
Lauderdale Manny good morning
good morning Vlad here we are nearly two
days after that record rainfall and
there are parts of the city that still
have this much standing water and there
were downpours again yesterday
preventing this water from more quickly
receding
Rescue Team spent Thursday going door to
door looking for stranded families in
some of Fort Lauderdale's hardest hit
neighborhoods but we're doing the best
we can with what we have First
Responders received nearly 1 000 calls
for help after more than 20 inches of
rain Wednesday caused catastrophic
flooding in some parts of the city I'm
Oscars but I'm okay
volunteers stepped in to help with the
rescues some using swamp buggies to take
families to safety some residents could
be seen wading through the water lugging
their belongings in boxes wrapped in
plastic to keep them dry
one local fire department had to pull
this abandoned car out of a small pond
after it got trapped during flash floods
and the roof of this shopping center is
thought to have collapsed under the
weight of all the excess water there are
no reports of injuries the amount of
rainfall is unprecedented some of the
most intense flooding was at the Fort
Lauderdale Airport which was forced to
shut down operations after more than two
feet of water flooded runways canceling
more than 800 flights we finally get off
the exit to the airport and it's at
airport closed the lagaras family was
among the thousands of stranded
passengers Wednesday night we spent the
night here we spent the night here all
night at the terminal and when do you
get to go home well we don't know
I checked in on them last night they
said they were able to get a rental car
which is hard to do right now and drive
the two hours to Fort Myers they're
hoping to get on a noon flight today
Tony
we wish them the best and everyone there
dealing with all of that water in South
Florida Manny thank you very much